[Music]
swimming with whales has been described
as one of the most
breathtaking experiences on earth and
today
you get to try it out as you get so
close to the majestic beasts that you
can almost pat them
you realize you've never felt this in
touch with nature before
[Music]
but then everything goes dark and your
body is tossed around aggressively
you've just been scooped up in a whale's
mouth
you struggle to find your way out but
what are your chances against a 15-ton
animal here's how to survive getting
swallowed by a whale
most people would tell you that being
swallowed by a whale is an immediate
death sentence
and they'd have good reason for it but
that doesn't mean that survival
is impossible just ask rayner schiff
in 2007 he was gobbled up by a whale
while taking pictures off south africa's
coast
he immediately held his breath until the
whale promptly spit him back out
but what if you weren't released so
quickly how could you avoid being sliced
up by the whale's teeth
is there any way to survive the burning
acids of its four stomachs
and when would be a bad time to make
your escape
here are some ways that you could get
out alive
oh and just to be clear there's only one
type of whale that could theoretically
swallow a human hole
most people would think that's the blue
whale blue whales have giant mouths that
could fit hundreds of people inside
and they keep their mouths wide open as
they travel through the ocean
but the baleen plates inside their
mouths would prevent a person from being
swallowed
even if someone did make it past those
the blue whale's esophagus is only 25
centimeters across
too small to allow a human through
the only whales that would have no
trouble swallowing us humans
are sperm whales so let's see how we can
avoid becoming their dinner
[Music]
number one curl up into a tight ball
bring your arms and legs into your body
as tightly as you can and lower your
chin to your chest
you need to curl up into the tightest
ball you can this will minimize your
body's surface area
and decrease the chance you'll get
chomped up by the whale's teeth
sperm whales have 18 to 26 teeth on each
side of their jaws
and each tooth weighs up to one kilogram
even if you were curled up into a ball
you'd still be lucky to make it through
the mouth without losing an arm or leg
but at least you'd have a chance number
two
don't panic yes we realize that's easier
said than done
but there is no time for fear in a
situation like this
you have to use your instincts try to
feel around in the mouth before you get
swallowed
it will be extremely dark but if you can
find something to hold on to
you won't get burned and digested in any
of the whale's four stomachs
you could try to grab onto the walls of
the esophagus but that would be very
difficult
as it's covered in mucus number three
wear a protective suit some people might
think you're a little paranoid when you
show up to swim with the whales in your
elaborate wetsuit
but it could very well save your life
you would want a suit that's resistant
to hydrochloric acid
so that it could survive in the whale's
stomachs one type of suit that might do
the trick
is called a neoprene wetsuit there is
some evidence that it could withstand
the harsh environment in the stomach
you would also need a breathing tube and
an oxygen reservoir
because there wouldn't be any breathable
air
number four wait to be spit up
it worked for our friend rainer shim so
why couldn't it work for you
he was lucky enough to be spit out
before he was swallowed
but in your case it's going to be a
little more difficult
and gross luckily for you
sperm whales need to vomit every several
hours so if you were able to survive
long enough
you could be spit up with it but don't
get too excited
because surviving all depends on where
you get spit out
whales can swim at a depth of 100 meters
whereas the human body can only swim at
a depth of 20 meters without assistance
so if the whale's thinking of spewing
you out on the deep part of his swim
you've probably got a better chance
living through it if you just stay
inside
[Music]
number five avoid sperm whales
it might seem like common sense but if
you want to avoid being swallowed by
a whale how about you just stay away
from the only ones that can swallow
humans
if another type of whale scoops you up
in their mouth you'll have a much better
chance of survival
take the humpback whale for instance
when this whale approaches a potential
meal
such as a school of krill they propel
themselves forward with a burst of
energy
open their mouths wide and let whatever
is in their way
flood in when something larger than
krill enters their mouths
they'll use their tongues to force it
back out
as you have probably gathered by now
even though it is technically possible
to survive being swallowed by a whale
it's extremely unlikely but luckily for
us
whales are generally not that interested
in humans
if you are going to worry about anything
eating you in the water it should
probably be sharks
and even if you run into them we've got
just the video
to help you get out alive
[Music]